ja die Energie das ist eigentlich das
Thema was uns hier alle am Tisch aber ja
auch die Gesellschaft so sehr
beschäftigt vor allem die Grünen sperren
sich gegen Atomkraft heute aber machte
dann ein Statement pro Atomkraft die
Runde und das kommt von niemand
geringerem ich kann es selbst kaum
glauben als der Grünen Vorkämpferin
gegen den Klimawandel Greta Thunberg
Köln wird doch einmal rein
denke das ist eine schlechte Idee ist
auf Kohle zu setzen solange die AKWs
noch laufen aber für das Klima wären die
Atomkraftwerke die bessere Wahl
zumindest für diesen Moment
es kommt darauf an wenn sie schon laufen
glaube ich dass es ein Fehler wäre sie
abzuschalten und sich der Kohle
zuzuwenden
jetzt spricht sich also selbst Greta
Thunberg für ein weiter Betrieb der
Atomkraftwerke aus das lässt mich zu der
Frage kommen ist Robert Habeck etwa
ideologischer als Greta Thunberg
Alexander küssler ja das ist natürlich
interessant dass immer spricht ja
manchmal von Friendly Fire und ist ein
klassisches Friendly Fire also die Ikone
der Fridays for future Bewegung die ja
große Schnittmengen hat mit den Grünen
mit den Basis Grün vor allem in
niedersächsischen Grünen auch sagt nun
letzten Endes ist die CO2-Bilanz
natürlich von einem Atomkraftwerk besser
als von Kohlekraftwerken insofern bitte
lasst doch die bestehenden Fliesen ich
bin der Meinung man sollte Frau tholberg
nicht überbewerten sie ist nicht die
Kindliche Kaiserin nicht das Orakel aus
Nordeuropa den man
muss ja nicht huldigen also ich habe mal
Buch geschrieben infantile Gesellschaft
ist mit einem Kapitel drin aber sie hat
natürlich alles rechter Welt diese
Meinung zu haben und sie zeigt natürlich
damit auf dass man im Zweifelsfall
wirklich auch mal den Mut haben muss
pragmatisch zu sein und es ist bis heute
nicht erklärt worden von Herrn Habig
vielleicht jetzt ein Parteitag am
Wochenende in Bonn warum die zwei wir
immer so schön sagt die zwei
süddeutschen Atomkraftwerke weiter
betrieben werden sollen das norddeutsche
das niedersächsische aller nicht für
allen wissen dass in Niedersachsen
Gorleben Bewegung die Keimzelle ist der
anti-acker w-bewegung aber es gibt jetzt
einen riesigen Zoff zwischen Christian
Lindner und Robert habe der hat sich
heute auch noch mal zugespitzt als
Politik Journalist kannst du sie
vielleicht mal kurz anreißen warum die
beiden so gar nicht mehr ja sich grün
sind sie sind sich nicht grün und ich
glaube er habe bereut es nee Herr
Lindner bereut ist mittlerweile dass er
sich mit einem grünen einen
Kabinettstisch gesetzt hat weil er also
grün wird durch diese grüne grüne
Anwesenheit am Körper netztisch es geht
darum dass er Lindner jetzt auch im Zuge
der schlechten Wahlergebnisse denke ich
mal Niedersachsen zeigen und sagen will
wir setzen durch Vernunft und das heißt
natürlich sie mehr tunbergwagen drei
Atomkraftwerke ja habe gesagt es sei
beschlossen worden erstmal nur zwei Herr
Lindner sagt meine Unterschrift also das
Finanzministers bekommt die Einigung
allerdings nur wenn wir alle drei
weiterlaufen lassen die FDP sagt es gab
keine Einigung die Grünen sagen Herr
habix sei Herr Lindner sein wortbrüchig
geworden das heißt jede Kleinigkeit wird
nun benutzt um ein Zoff hoch zu kochen
und das hier ist eben keine Kleinigkeit
es geht um die Versorgung Sicherheit im
nächsten Winter nächsten Winterhalbjahr
das heißt letzten Endes sollte hier
Habeck muss er habe über seinen Schatten
springen Herr spiegelsberger sie sind
blackout-experte auch und Experte für
Krisen Versorgung was sagen sie denn mit
Blick auf Robert Habeck ist das noch
verständlich also ich meine selbst Greta
Tomberg die er wirklich ich muss sagen
ich würde sie jetzt nicht so oft
zitieren die klimaaktivisten aber was
sagen sie denn dazu dass die jetzt
eigentlich schon weniger ideologische
Sätze Habeck ja es ist also ich finde es
super weil das Problem an ist ja das
diese drei Atomkraftwerke produzieren
Strom für 10,5 Millionen Haushalte und
durch die Gaskrise und da wir immer mehr
auf Gaskraftwerke setzen in der
Energiewende wir haben ja Atomkraftwerke
gebaut Kohlekraftwerke und diese zum
Großteil durch Gaskraftwerk ersetzt Gas
ist momentan sehr knapp wenn man jetzt
natürlich noch Gas verstrumen müssen
weil sie nicht wie das funktioniert also
ob es funktioniert gehen wir dann später
drauf aber wie gesagt wenn man die
abschalten ist für mich völlig
unverständlich wie man in so einer
Situation der Kernkraftwerk abschalten
kann das weiterhin Strom liefert als
tomberg-fan bezeichnen das hätte ich nie
gedacht aber heute ja heute sind Sie
Greta Tumor gefahren das ist auch
erlaubt denn jetzt ja vielleicht ganz
Deutschland zum Fan von Greta Thunberg
oder besser formuliert kann zerobert
Habeck sogar dazu bringen weil die
Grünen hören ja schon sehr auf die
Community der klimaaktivisten ja das
sollten Sie tun also und meines Wissens
hat sie das auch schon früher gesagt
also eigentlich ist das gar keine
Überraschung und muss einfach mal auch
über die Landesgrenze hinaus sehen grüne
in anderen Ländern sagen durchaus andere
Sachen als Grüne in Deutschland
in insofern also ich würde da auch noch
nicht zum Fan werden es gibt auch noch
ein paar andere Aussagen aber im Großen
und Ganzen glaube ich muss man jetzt
darauf setz alle Reserven zu
mobilisieren die da sind und und die
nicht mit mit großem Aufwand erst wieder
also in Gang gebracht werden müssen also
deswegen das glaube ich werden viele
Leute auch nicht verstehen wenn es
wirklich zu Blackouts oder anderen
Krisen kommt wenn hier nicht alles getan
wurde aber es hängt an Scholz er muss
jetzt vermitteln zwischen diesen beiden
Positionen es ist es wirklich seine
Richtlinienkompetenz gefragt der ist ja
in letzter Zeit nicht immer nachgekommen
muss man schon sagen aber jetzt geht es
nicht erkannt diesen Streit nicht
weiterlaufen lassen die Ampel fährt
sonst das Land an die Wand es gibt ja
auch in der SPD viele Atomkraftgegner
aber er wird man wie würden Sie denn den
aktuellen energiekrieg bewerten den wir
uns befinden
schon seit vielen Jahren ist für
Russland unter Putin Energie eine Waffe
und was die heutige Situation angeht da
warne ich vor zu viel Panikmache auch
seitens des Wirtschaftsministers wir
sind in vielen Dingen in unserer
Wirtschaft eigentlich viel findiger und
flexibler als man das manchmal glaubt
und ich habe eine Sorge dass hier eine
Kriegsmüdigkeit unserer Bevölkerung
Eintritt angesichts der wirtschaftlichen
und sozialen Folgen natürlich ist das
bedrückend aber sollte Putin gewinnen
dann wäre der Preis für uns alle viel
höher als das was wir jetzt an Inflation
und Energiekosten auszuhalten haben
es spiegelsberger nicht zu viel Panik
verbreiten das muss ja eigentlich bei
ihnen klingen man sollte eher noch mehr
Panik verbreiten oder wie würden Sie das
sehen wenn es hilft dass ich die
Menschen dort vorbereiten auf das was
vielleicht kommen könnte dann okay aber
eigentlich braucht man Körper Panik
verbreiten wenn man gewisse
Vorbereitungsmaßnahmen dann für einen
persönlich wäre auch ein Blackout nicht
so schlimm nur leider sind 85% aller
Personen in Deutschland nicht
vorbereitet und das ist eigentlich das
große Problem was mir dann letztendlich
haben beim Blackout ich tue auch dazu
übrigens ich habe mich auch noch nicht
vorbereitet was müsste ich denn jetzt
tun wenn ich mich vorbereiten will ich
würde auf jeden Fall immer nicht alles
auf einmal machen das ist mir das
Wichtigste sondern einfach bei jedem
Einkauf zum Beispiel bei Kiste Wasser
mitnehmen zusätzlich oder mal ein paar
Dosen mitnehmen dass man zumindest
dieses Thema schon mal geklärt hat dann
was viele leider unterschätzen ist es
ist ja stockfinster es geht ja kein
Straßenlaterne es geht Kohl Radio es
gibt kein Fernsehen es geht nichts es
ist stille man hört plötzlich Geräusche
die man noch nie im Leben vorher gehört
hat und dann fängt natürlich die Psyche
an einer Streich zu spielen und wenn
dann draußen irgendwas raschelt man hat
vielleicht nicht einmal Taschenlampe
dass man nachschauen könnte ob das jetzt
am aus ist oder ob da jemand draußen
steht dann hat man natürlich ein großes
Problem wenn sie dann ein gewisses
Surren hören dann ist das meine Dynamo
Taschenlampe die ich von meiner Mutter
noch habe sie hat einen Bügel und
einfach durch ständiges Betätigen des
Bügels hat man Licht aber nur Reichweite
von drei vier Meter und der moderne
Hotel mehrere hundert Meter Reichweite
hoffen wir
mal das kommen muss zum Einsatz